Muy buenas tardes para todos ustedes
Pues un partido de locura el que
acabamos de vivir aquí en el estadio el
ranup un partido entre Camerún y Serbia
partido que se termina tres goles por
tres todo eso A pesar de que los
acerbios Pues en el primer tiempo habían
dominado fueron quien más tuvieron
ocasiones sobre todo por parte de Sin
embargo Pues fue Camerún el que abrió el
marcador en el minuto 29 con un gol de
pelota quieta de castleto ahora después
de esto finalmente los serbios
continuaron Buscando el gol y en tan
solo dos minutos remontaron goles de
Pablo Beach y de
millenco para el segundo tiempo pues
hacer Ya volvió a salir así bastante
fuerte parecía que ya había en el minuto
53 Perdón ya digamos que tenía este
partido prácticamente en el bolsillo con
un tercer gol el de mitrovich por fin y
sin embargo Pues los leones Indomables
de Camerún continuaron buscando la
manera marcar y lo lograron en tan solo
tres minutos también pues fue a bubacar
primero y luego fue el mismo bubacar
quien dio el pase gol para este partido
pues se termina tres goles por 3 tuvo de
hecho ya en los últimos minutos de este
partido una pelota para marcar el cuarto
gol y quizás llevarse la victoria Pero
bueno por ahora pues es quizás el mejor
de los partidos en todo caso muy una
gran locura aquí en el llano Natalia
también cómo se estarían preparando las
elecciones de Brasil y Suiza para su
encuentro y otros partidos podemos ver
hoy
ya sabemos que Neymar no estará en este
partido tampoco Danilo Así que a ti te
habría haría algunos cambios en su
sistema se espera que entre paqueta y
que sea militado aquí en la reemplace a
Daniel o Suiza no tiene mayores para
realizar sobre todo que tiene en punta
de embolo quien fue el jugador que le
dio la victoria a suiza que ella también
tiene tres puntos como Brasil importante
de todas maneras lo que suceda esta
noche para definir lo que ocurre en este
grupo en cuanto a los otros partidos
pues ya tenemos a Corea del Sur que
enfrentará a ghana mientras que
tendremos Portugal Uruguay y por
supuesto este Brasil o suizo para el día
de hoy Así que Portugal Uruguay que es
un partido que ya de hecho se jugó Hace
cuatro años Así que los portugueses
esperan tener revancha en ese momento
porque fue Uruguay la que sacó
finalmente al equipo de Cristiano
Ronaldo En esa ocasión así que ya hoy
pues ya se determinarán cómo quedan ya
estos dos últimos grupos aquí en